- Vítej v kurzu Porozumění
kvantovým informacím a výpočtům.
Jmenuji se John Watrous a jsem technický ředitel
IBM Quantum Education.
Cílem této série je poskytnout ti
solidní porozumění kvantovým informacím a výpočtům, a to znamená jít
do technických detailů
kvantových informací a vidět, jak kvantové
výpočty skutečně fungují, co umí a co neumí.
Pokud jsi ještě nesledoval
přehledové video k této sérii, doporučuji ti ho zhlédnout.
V tom videu najdeš informace o tom, jaká příprava na pozadí
je pro tuto sérii doporučena, a také osnovu
témat, která budou pokryta.
Také se nezapomeň podívat
na Qiskit textbook, který pokrývá stejnou
látku jako tato videoserie, ale v písemné formě,
a také obsahuje
interaktivní komponenty a rozhraní k hardwaru a softwaru, navržené tak, aby ti pomohly lépe porozumět
kvantovým informacím a výpočtům. Odkazy na přehledové video a Qiskit textbook
najdeš v popisu.
Toto je lekce jedna
první jednotky série.
První jednotka pokrývá základy
kvantových informací, a v první lekci této jednotky se zaměříme na to, jak
kvantové informace fungují
pro jednotlivé systémy, tedy že máme
jen jeden fyzický systém nebo nějaké zařízení,
které uchovává kvantové informace,
a uvažujeme, jak tento
jeden systém nebo zařízení funguje v izolaci.
V lekci, která tuto následuje, probereme, jak
kvantové informace fungují, když máme více systémů, a to nám umožní
popisovat zajímavé
a důležité koncepty, jako jsou kvantové algoritmy využívající více qubitů
a kvantové protokoly
zahrnující více jednotlivců, kteří zpracovávají kvantové informace a přenášejí je tam
a zpět mezi sebou.
Ale než se do těchto diskusí pustíme, dává smysl začít se
srovnávacím jednoduchým nastavením jednoho systému v izolaci,
zčásti proto, že je dobré začít jednoduše, ale také proto, jak uvidíme, popis toho, jak
kvantové informace fungují
pro jednotlivé systémy v izolaci přirozeně a logicky vede k popisu toho, jak
pro více systémů.
Tady je stručný přehled lekce.
Začneme diskusí o
klasických informacích.
Účelem této lekce není vysvětlit, jak
fungují klasické informace, ale jak
fungují kvantové informace,
ale abychom vysvětlili, jak
kvantové informace fungují, je velmi užitečné začít
s klasickými informacemi a využít je jako
známý referenční bod,
když budeme diskutovat o kvantových informacích.
Na matematické úrovni mají kvantové a klasické informace vlastně docela podobné popisy s některými klíčovými rozdíly, samozřejmě.
Ve skutečnosti kvantové informace
vůbec nejsou odděleny od klasických informací.
Jsou rozšířením
klasických informací.
Pravdou je,
alespoň podle mého názoru, že kvantovým informacím
nemůžeš skutečně porozumět, pokud nerozumíš
klasickým informacím,
takže začít s klasickými
informacemi dává smysl.
Očekávám, že tento
obsah bude pro některé diváky povědomý, ale i pokud ho znáš, nedoporučuji přeskočit ho.
Kromě zdůraznění aspektů klasických informací, které jsou nejrelevantnější pro
porozumění kvantovým informacím, představíme v této části
Diracovu notaci,
což je standardní způsob,
jakým budeme popisovat vektory a
matice v celé sérii.
Ukazuje se, že Diracova notace není
specifická pro kvantové informace.
Stejně dobře ji lze použít v kontextu klasických informací, ale i v mnoha jiných situacích, kde se vektory a matice vyskytují.
Pak přejdeme ke kvantovým informacím, a konkrétně probereme
reprezentaci kvantových stavů jako vektorů,
jednoduchý typ měření zvaný měření ve standardní bázi, a unitární operace, které popisují diskrétní časové
změny v kvantových systémech.
Opět vše v nastavení
jednotlivých systémů.
Než začneme samotnou lekcí, bude užitečné objasnit, že existují vlastně dva popisy
kvantových informací: zjednodušený popis, na který se
zaměříme v této lekci
a v průběhu celé první jednotky, a obecný popis, který je pokryt v pozdější jednotce, konkrétně ve
třetí jednotce série.
Zjednodušený popis,
věrný svému názvu, je jednodušší a
obvykle se učí jako první.
Ve zjednodušeném popisu, jak jsem již naznačil, jsou kvantové stavy reprezentovány vektory a operace jsou reprezentovány
unitárními maticemi.
Tento popis kvantových
informací je dostatečný pro porozumění
většině kvantových algoritmů, například,
takže není přílišně zjednodušený, je to ta pravá věc.
Nicméně, jak postupně
zjistíme, má jisté omezení.
Například, pokud chceme
modelovat účinky šumu na kvantové systémy, tento popis se ukáže jako nedostačující.
WEBVTT
Obecný popis je na druhé
straně obecnější a v konečném důsledku je matematicky
výkonnější.
V tomto popisu jsou kvantové stavy reprezentovány speciální třídou matic
zvaných matice hustoty,
a lze popsat obecnější třídu
měření a operací, včetně
šumu, například.
Je zcela konzistentní se
zjednodušeným popisem, a vlastně lze
zjednodušený popis
v podstatě chápat jako speciální případ
obecného popisu, přičemž ten také zahrnuje klasické informace jako speciální případ.
Je také opravdu dost
krásný v tom, jak to vše funguje, takže tě silně vybízím, abys se o tomto obecném popisu dozvěděl více,
až přijde ten správný čas, ale zjednodušený popis je přirozenějším místem, kde začít, a proto to tak uděláme.
Začneme tím, že si promluvíme o klasických informacích s ohledem na aspekty
klasických informací, které jsou nejrelevantnější
pro kvantové informace,
a způsob, jakým jsou
matematicky popsány.
Představ si, že máme
fyzický systém nebo nějaké zařízení, které uchovává informace.
Tomuto systému dáme název X, ale na tomto názvu
nic důležitého není.
Mohli bychom použít jakýkoliv jiný
název, pokud bychom upřednostňovali, ale abychom si jeden vybrali,
nazveme systém X.
Uděláme předpoklad o X, totiž že existuje
konečná množina klasických stavů, ve kterých může X být
v jakémkoliv daném okamžiku.
Když zde odkazuji na klasický stav, myslím tím konfiguraci systému, která může být rozpoznána a
jednoznačně popsána
bez jakékoliv nejistoty nebo chyby.
Toto je vlastně něco, o čem můžeš uvažovat intuitivně. Na matematické úrovni jednoduše definujeme
množinu klasických stavů,
volíme ji tak, jak chceme, nebo jakýmkoliv způsobem, který nejlépe
popisuje zařízení, se kterým pracujeme.
Dejme název sigma
této množině klasických stavů, a opět zdůraznim,
že předpokládáme, že sigma je konečná množina.
Množina klasických
stavů tohoto systému X není nekonečně velká jako
množina všech přirozených čísel.
Je konečná, a to je jen
předpoklad, který děláme.
Například, X může být bit, v takovém případě je množina klasických stavů množina obsahující dva
prvky: nulu a jedničku.
Tuto množinu někdy označujeme
jako binární abecedu.
Dalším příkladem je, že X je
obyčejná šestistranná kostka, v takovém případě jsou klasické stavy čísla jedna až šest.
Samozřejmě, mluvíme zde
o abstrakci.
Skutečná šestistranná kostka může
mít mnoho různých atributů, jako je její přesná
poloha, orientace,
teplota atd. Ale s ohledem na informace, které jsou nejčastěji relevantní, když mluvíme o šestistranné kostce,
jsou klasické stavy
čísla jedna až šest označená počtem teček na té straně kostky, která je otočena nahoru.
Pokud X je vypínač na
standardním elektrickém ventilátoru, který bys mohl mít doma, pak jsou klasické stavy možná
nastavení vysoký,
střední, nízký a vypnuto.
To jsou jen příklady. Mohli bychom si představit systémy mající různé
množiny klasických stavů, ale doufám, že zprostředkovávají myšlenku,
že tento pojem klasického stavu je něco, co by mělo být
povědomé a lze to pochopit v jednoduchých a intuitivních termínech.
Matematicky řečeno, množina klasických stavů
je jen konečná množina, a tato množina samozřejmě musí
být také neprázdná.
Musí existovat alespoň
jeden klasický stav, ve kterém může systém být, a musí existovat alespoň dva klasické stavy,
pokud má být systém vůbec užitečný pro uchovávání informací.
Nyní, v některých situacích, bychom mohli vědět, že X je
v nějakém konkrétním stavu, ale v mnoha situacích,
které se vyskytují v kontextu
zpracování informací, může existovat nejistota ohledně klasického stavu systému
v konkrétním okamžiku,
takže každý možný klasický stav má přiřazenou určitou pravděpodobnost.
Například, pokud X je bit, pak možná X je v klasickém stavu nula
s pravděpodobností tři čtvrtiny a je ve stavu jedna
s pravděpodobností jedna čtvrtina.
Budeme to označovat
jako pravděpodobnostní stav, a tento pravděpodobnostní stav bychom mohli vyjádřit, jak vidíš právě zde,
jednoduše tím, že uvedeme
jaké jsou pravděpodobnosti pro různé klasické stavy.
Stručnější způsob vyjádření
tohoto pravděpodobnostního stavu je vektorem, konkrétně reprezentace,
kterou vidíš právě zde,
je sloupcový vektor, a tento vektor udává,
jaké jsou pravděpodobnosti pro dva možné klasické stavy.
Konkrétněji, první složka udává
jaká je pravděpodobnost, že X je ve stavu nula, a druhá složka nám říká, jaká je pravděpodobnost,
že systém je ve stavu jedna. Toto je jednoduše přirozený způsob uspořádání binární abecedy,
nebo alespoň to je způsob,
jakým jsme to naučeni dělat. S nulou jako první a jedničkou jako druhou.
Do budoucna budeme používat
termín vektor pravděpodobností pro označení takového vektoru.
WEBVTT
Konkrétně je to vektor, jehož složky jsou všechny
nezáporná reálná čísla a kde součet
složek se rovná jedné,
takže dává smysl uvažovat o těchto složkách jako o pravděpodobnostech.
V tomto příkladu jsou jen dvě složky, protože existují jen dva
klasické stavy systému, o kterém mluvíme,
ale obecně může existovat
libovolný počet složek, přičemž se rozumí, že existuje jedna složka pro každý klasický stav
ať už mluvíme o jakémkoliv systému.
Budeme pokračovat
v diskusi o klasických informacích, vektorech pravděpodobností a
tak dále za chvíli, ale nejprve bude opravdu užitečné
představit notaci
pro popis vektorů známou jako Diracova notace.
Ve skutečnosti toto je jen první
část Diracovy notace.
Existuje několik dalších
aspektů Diracovy notace, které uvidíme o něco
později v lekci.
Tato notace bude
ústřední pro způsob, jakým popisujeme kvantové informace, takže je nezbytné
pochopit, jak funguje,
ale naštěstí je velmi jednoduchá a nemá vlastně
nic specifického společného s kvantovými informacemi,
takže ji nyní můžeme představit
v povědomém kontextu klasických informací.
Jako dříve, předpokládáme, že máme množinu sigma
klasických stavů nějakého systému, a předpokládáme,
že máme uspořádání
těchto klasických stavů, stejně jako odkazujeme na
uspořádání binární abecedy
v předchozím příkladu. Jiný způsob, jak to říci,
je, že prvky sigma jsou dány do korespondence
s celými čísly
od jedné do toho, kolik
prvků sigma obsahuje, což je to, co tato notace s dvěma čarami kolem sigma znamená.
To je počet
prvků v množině sigma.
Takže existuje první stav,
druhý stav, a tak dále.
Konkrétní uspořádání nebo
korespondence, kterou zvolíme, ve skutečnosti nebude příliš záležet.
Co je skutečně důležité,
je to, že máme uspořádání a držíme se ho.
Pro mnoho množin klasických stavů,
se kterými se setkáme, bude existovat standardní uspořádání, stejně jako máme s
binární abecedou,
a pokud žádné standardní uspořádání neexistuje, můžeme si jen jedno zvolit.
Ale ať je jakékoliv, rozumí se, že se ho držíme.
Nyní, tady je notace,
která se zavádí.
Pro jakoukoliv volbu klasického
stavu a z naší množiny sigma, napíšeme toto, co vidíš právě zde, což se čte jako ket a,
a znamená to sloupcový vektor,
který má jedničku ve složce odpovídající a a nulu pro všechny ostatní složky.
Například, pokud se vrátíme
k binární abecedě, která, jak jsi asi uhodl, je velmi důležitý příklad,
ke kterému se budeme znovu a znovu vracet. Pak ket nula a ket jedna jsou vektory definované právě zde.
Ket nula je vektor,
který má jedničku ve složce odpovídající klasickému stavu nula, což je první složka,
a nulu pro všechny ostatní složky, a v tomto případě existuje
jen jedna další složka.
Podobně, ket jedna je
tento vektor právě zde, kde máme jedničku ve
složce odpovídající jedné,
což je druhá složka, a nulu pro všechny ostatní složky, což je, opět, jen jedna složka.
Tady je další příklad. V tomto příkladu máme množinu klasických stavů sigma odpovídající čtyřem barvám
ve standardním balíčku hracích karet: kříže, káry, srdce a piky.
V tomto případě neexistuje
obecně dohodnuté uspořádání těchto barev.
V mnoha karetních hrách neexistuje žádné uspořádání. Jsou to jen čtyři různé barvy a to je vše, co záleží, a existují různé karetní
hry, které tyto barvy uspořádávají
různými způsoby, ale nezáleží na tom.
Můžeme si jen zvolit
uspořádání jako to, které vidíš právě zde.
Toto se stane abecedním uspořádáním podle názvů těchto čtyř barev napsaných v angličtině,
Předpokládejme, že jsme zvolili
toto konkrétní uspořádání, pak definujeme tyto čtyři vektory: ket clubs, ket diamonds,
ket hearts a ket spades,
jak vidíš právě zde, a tyto vektory odpovídají
obecnému popisu, který vidíš nahoře.
Vzhledem k tomu, že jsme zvolili
toto konkrétní uspořádání pro tyto čtyři barvy.
Totéž můžeme udělat pro libovolnou množinu klasických stavů,
kterou zvolíme.
Mějme na paměti, že množina klasických
stavů vždy znamená konečnou a neprázdnou množinu.
Vektory tohoto tvaru se
nazývají vektory standardní báze, a je to velmi základní fakt o vektorech, že každý vektor může být
vyjádřen jedinečným způsobem
jako lineární kombinace
vektorů standardní báze.
Například, vrátíme-li se k příkladu před chvílí, vektor pravděpodobností,
který jsme viděli, může být vyjádřen
jak vidíš právě zde. Je to v podstatě jen alternativní způsob vyjadřování vektorů,
který bude velmi užitečný z několika důvodů do budoucna.
WEBVTT
A s touto notací nyní v rukou se vraťme k diskusi
o klasických informacích a zejména o pravděpodobnostních stavech.
Uvažujme, co se stane,
když měříme systém, zatímco je v nějakém pravděpodobnostním stavu.
V klasickém kontextu bychom
obvykle nemluvili o měření nebo o aktu měření
něčeho, ale tento termín má smysl.
V podstatě, když mluvíme
o měření systému X v tomto kontextu, jednoduše tím myslíme, že se na něj podíváme a rozpoznáme, v jakém stavu se nachází.
Samozřejmě, když se na systém podíváme, nevidíme pravděpodobnostní stav, vidíme klasický stav,
a konkrétní
klasický stav, který vidíme, je ten, o němž si můžeme představit, že je vybrán náhodně podle pravděpodobností.
Nyní bys mohl namítat z
filozofických důvodů proti myšlence, že klasický stav, který vidíme, je nějak vybrán náhodně
v okamžiku, kdy měříme nebo se díváme na systém — systém jednoduše byl v nějakém konkrétním
klasickém stavu po celou dobu,
a my jsme jednoduše
zjistili, jaký ten stav byl, ale pro účely přemýšlení o matematickém
rámci, se kterým pracujeme,
je v pořádku takhle o tom přemýšlet, a tím nám to umožní nakreslit paralelu s
kvantovými informacemi o něco později.
Předpokládejme, že
klasický stav, který vidíme, je klasický stav a, což může být jakýkoliv stav v naší množině sigma.
Tím se obecně mění pravděpodobnostní
stav X, alespoň z našeho pohledu.
Pravděpodobnosti již nemají
žádný význam, protože nyní víme, jaký
je klasický stav X.
Je to a, a o tomto
již není žádná nejistota.
Takže bychom nyní řekli, že
pravděpodobnost, že systém je ve stavu a, je jedna.
Víme to, protože jsme se právě podívali a viděli jsme, že klasický stav je a, takže nový pravděpodobnostní stav X je ten,
ve kterém je pravděpodobnost
bytí v klasickém stavu a rovna jedné.
A tento pravděpodobnostní stav je reprezentován
vektorem pravděpodobností ket a.
Máme jedničku ve složce odpovídající klasickému stavu a a nulu ve všech ostatních složkách.
Například, pokud opět
uvažujeme situaci, kdy X je bit a máme stejný
pravděpodobnostní stav jako dříve,
pak pokud měříme X, můžeme si představit, že
dochází k přechodu.
S pravděpodobností tři čtvrtiny vidíme klasický stav nula, a měřením přejdeme na ket nula
jako náš pravděpodobnostní stav,
a s pravděpodobností jedna čtvrtina přejdeme na ket jedna.
Pokud chceš, můžeš o tom přemýšlet jako o přechodu znalostí, na rozdíl od skutečného
fyzického přechodu,
ale co je důležité pro
účely této lekce, je rozpoznat, jak funguje matematika.
Je to vlastně celkem triviální, ale rozpoznáním této triviality, analogický popis
pro kvantové nastavení
může vypadat trochu méně záhadně.
Poslední poznámka je, že jiné osobě, která náhodou neviděla, jaký
byl klasický stav X, když jsme ho měřili,
se přirozeně pravděpodobnostní stav
nezmění v důsledku toho, že jsme ho měřili.
To je v pořádku. Různí jednotlivci mohou
mít různé znalosti o konkrétním systému a odpovídajícím způsobem volit
různé pravděpodobnostní stavy,
aby reprezentovaly jejich
znalost tohoto systému.
V poslední části této diskuse o klasických informacích si promluvíme o klasických operacích, které lze provádět na systému,
počínaje deterministickými operacemi.
Když provádíme operaci na systému, jeho stav se obecně změní jako výsledek, a v tomto kontextu slovo deterministický znamená,
že výsledek provedení
operace závisí výhradně na tom, jaký klasický
stav byl systém
před provedením operace.
Jinými slovy, při provedení deterministické
operace neexistuje žádný prvek náhody, takže není zahrnuta žádná náhodnost
nebo nejistota.
V matematických termínech jsou deterministické operace
popsány funkcemi.
Každá funkce f tvaru,
který vidíš právě zde, což znamená, že jak vstup, tak výstup funkce
odpovídají prvkům
naší množiny klasických stavů sigma, popisuje deterministickou operaci.
Klasický stav a je
transformován do stavu f z a pro každou volbu stavu a.
Pro každou funkci f tohoto tvaru vždy existuje jedinečná matice M splňující tuto podmínku, kterou vidíš právě zde,
a to totiž, že vynásobení
M k vektoru ket a nám dává vektor ket f z a,
a to platí pro každou
volbu klasického stavu a.
Není příliš těžké zapsat
explicitní popis M při jakékoliv funkci f
tohoto tvaru, kterou jsme zvolili.
Vždy bude mít přesně
jednu jedničku v každém sloupci, přičemž každá ostatní složka se rovná nule.
A tady je vzorec. Složka b, a matice M se rovná jedné, pokud se b rovná f z a,
a jinak se rovná nule, a tím myslíme,
že toto je složka M, jejíž řádek odpovídá b
a jejíž sloupec odpovídá a.
WEBVTT
Za chvíli uvidíme několik příkladů a pochopíme, proč tento vzorec funguje.
Teď možná není jasné, proč bychom chtěli vzít funkci a vyjádřit ji jako matici,
ale má to smysl. Jedním z důvodů, a možná je to hlavní důvod, je, že pokud máme systém
v pravděpodobnostním stavu
a provedeme deterministickou
operaci na tomto systému, pak výsledný pravděpodobnostní
stav lze získat
maticovým násobením vektoru, tj. pokud je náš systém
v pravděpodobnostním stavu
reprezentovaném
nějakým vektorem pravděpodobností v a provedeme deterministickou
operaci popsanou M
na tomto systému, pak výsledný pravděpodobnostní stav bude dán M krát v.
Tato šipka, mimochodem, s malou
čárou na ní, jak tuto vidíš, je jen běžná notace v matematice pro označení toho, jak se jedna
věc mapuje na
nebo transformuje do jiné věci. Mohl bys použít jen obyčejnou šipku, ale toto je konvenční
a je rozpoznatelná a možná je trochu specifičtější než jen šipka, která může znamenat mnoho různých věcí.
Nyní se podíváme na příklad nebo vlastně na kolekci příkladů.
Uvažujme, co se stane, když vezmeme naši množinu klasických stavů sigma jako opět binární abecedu.
Neexistuje příliš mnoho různých funkcí tvaru, o němž jsme diskutovali, když je toto naše množina klasických stavů, a přesněji řečeno, existují pouze čtyři
funkce tohoto tvaru.
Zde jsou tyto čtyři funkce popsány svými tzv. tabulkami hodnot.
První tabulka popisuje
první funkci, kterou jsme pojmenovali f1.
Pro každý možný vstup vlevo uvádíme odpovídající
výstup vpravo, takže f1 z nuly se rovná nule,
a f1 z jedničky se opět rovná nule, a to znamená, že f1 je
konstantní nulová funkce.
Vždy nabývá hodnoty nula.
Druhá funkce f2
je funkce identity.
Výstup se vždy rovná vstupu, jak vidíš z druhé tabulky.
Třetí funkce f3 je
popsána třetí tabulkou.
f3 z nuly se rovná jedné, a f3 z jedničky se rovná nule.
Tato funkce je lépe
známa jako funkce not nebo logická negace.
Někdy ji také nazýváme bit flip, protože převrátí nulu
na jedničku a jedničku na nulu.
Poslední funkce f4 je
opět konstantní funkce, stejně jako ta první, ale tato je konstantní jednová funkce,
protože vždy nabývá hodnoty jedna.
A to jsou jediné čtyři funkce z binární abecedy do sebe samé.
Zde jsou čtyři matice odpovídající těmto čtyřem funkcím, které jsou popsány
vzorcem z dřívějška,
který vidíš právě zde, a pokud máš chuť, můžeš video pozastavit a to zkontrolovat.
Jen mej na paměti, že u matic je pořadí indexů vždy nejdříve řádky, potom sloupce.
Takže složka b, a odpovídá
řádku b a sloupci a, neboli řádku, který odpovídá
klasickému stavu b,
a sloupci, který odpovídá
klasickému stavu a.
Takže například, pokud se podíváme
na první funkci, máme f1 z nuly se rovná nule,
a odpovídajícím způsobem, složka
nula, nula matice M1 se rovná jedné.
Složka jedna, nula,
která je právě tady, se rovná nule, a to samé lze udělat pro případ,
kdy se vstup rovná jedné, a podobně pro
ostatní tři funkce.
Můžeš také zkontrolovat, že tento
vzorec z dřívějška platí, a můžeš jednoduše projít všechny různé
možnosti a to ověřit.
A vlastně, pokud přemýšlíš o tom, jak
maticové násobení funguje, opravdu si to můžeš tak nějak jen odhadnout pohledem.
Když násobíš matici standardním bázovým vektorem, jako je tento, můžeš si představit, že
bereš vstup
a vkládáš ho do
vrcholu jedné z matic v příslušném sloupci odpovídajícím
klasickému stavu
uvnitř ketu, a výstup, který
dostaneš, je jednoduše tento sloupec jako vektor pravděpodobností.
Takže například, M3 vynásobené ketem
nula ti dá nula, jedna
jako vektor pravděpodobností, což je ket jedna.
M3 vynásobené ketem
jedna ti dá jedna, nula, což je ket nula, a tak dále.
Za chvíli si promluvíme více o operacích na
pravděpodobnostních stavech, ale nejprve si představme druhou část Diracovy notace.
To bude užitečné
pro mluvení o operacích a přemýšlení o nich jako o matici Cs, a také to bude standardní nástroj,
který budeme nadále používat. Nastavení je stejné jako předtím.
Máme jakoukoli množinu klasických stavů sigma, se kterou pracujeme, a předpokládáme, že máme nějaký způsob
uspořádání těchto klasických stavů.
Pak zapíšeme tuto věc,
kterou vidíš právě zde, kde tentokrát je
lomená čára vlevo, nikoli vpravo, a to označuje řádkový vektor mající jedničku
ve složce, která
odpovídá a, a nulu pro všechny ostatní složky odpovídající všem
ostatním klasickým stavům.
Takže rozdíl mezi
touto věcí a ketem a je, že toto je řádkový vektor a
ket a je sloupcový vektor,
WEBVTT
ale jinak jsou vektory
definovány podobným způsobem.
Toto čteme jako bra a, nevím, jestli to má být vtipné, ale myšlenka je taková, že názvy bra a ket
jsou dvě poloviny slova bracket, a o tom si budeme mít více co říct za chvíli.
Ale nejprve se podívejme
na velmi rychlý příklad.
Pro binární abecedu máme, že bra nula je
tento řádkový vektor právě zde, analogický k ket a,
jenže je to řádkový vektor
místo sloupcového vektoru, a bra jedna je tento vektor právě zde.
Nyní obecně, pokud vynásobíme řádkový
vektor sloupcovým vektorem, přemýšlíme o nich jako o maticích
s pouhým
jedním řádkem nebo jedním sloupcem, dostaneme matici jedna krát jedna, o které můžeme uvažovat
jako o skaláru.
Tady, mimochodem, bys měl
uvažovat o těchto hvězdičkách jako o reprezentujících libovolná čísla.
Konkrétně, pokud
vynásobíme řádkový vektor bra a sloupcovým vektorem ket b,
pak mohou nastat dvě věci.
Jedna je, že a a b jsou si rovny, takže jsou to stejné klasické stavy, v takovém případě se jedničky překryjí
a součin bude roven jedné, nebo by mohlo nastat, že
a a b jsou různé,
takže jedničky se nepřekrývají a součin se rovná nule.
Jednoduchý způsob vyjádření
těchto pozorování je tento právě zde.
A abychom udrželi věci v pořádku, zapíšeme tento součin takto s jednou čárou uprostřed, a to znamená přesně totéž
jako toto právě zde.
A nyní vidíš, jak
bra a ket dohromady tvoří bracket, který se
také nazývá vnitřní součin,
a to je něco
velmi důležitého, ke čemu se vrátíme
ve třetí lekci.
Vynásobení sloupcového
vektoru řádkovým vektorem, na druhou stranu, nám dává matici, jak vidíš právě zde.
Takže například, pokud se vrátíme ještě jednou
k binární abecedě, pokud vynásobíme ket nula braou nula,
dostaneme tuto matici právě zde, a můžeme projít
ostatními možnostmi a vidět, co se stane.
Ket nula krát bra jedna nám dává
tuto matici právě zde, kde se jednička přesunula
na tuto pozici.
Ket jedna, bra nula vypadá takto, a tady je ket jedna, bra jedna.
Vidíme, že existuje právě jedna jednička v matici, která je jinak samé nuly, a pozice té jedničky
je dána tím, které
klasické stavy zvolíme v bra a ketu.
Přesněji řečeno, a
toto platí obecně, pro jakoukoli volbu množiny klasických stavů, matice, kterou dostaneme vynásobením ket a braou b,
je matice s jedničkou ve složce a, b a nulou pro všechny ostatní složky.
A nyní, když máme první
a druhou část Diracovy notace, máme velmi praktický nástroj pro propojení operací s maticemi.
Takže se vrátíme stručně
k deterministickým operacím a připomeneme si, že o něco dříve v lekci
bylo řečeno, že pro každou funkci f
tohoto tvaru právě zde máme deterministickou operaci, která transformuje a do f z a
pro každý možný klasický stav a. A řekli jsme, že pro
jakoukoliv takovou funkci vždy existuje jedinečná
matice M, která takto funguje
na standardních bázových stavech.
Pomocí Diracovy notace nyní můžeme velmi snadno vyjádřit tuto matici, jak vidíš právě zde,
a vidíme, jak je někdy
možné pracovat s maticemi zcela
v rámci Diracovy notace
bez explicitního převodu
na vektory a matice, tj. obdélníky naplněné čísly.
V tomto případě můžeme zkontrolovat, že
požadovaný vzorec platí vynásobením M ketem a.
Dosadíme náš
výraz pro M takto a můžeme odstranit závorky a spojit bru
b s ketem a takto.
Je to proto, že maticové
násobení je lineární, v tomto případě v prvním argumentu, a je asociativní, takže můžeme závorky odstranit.
A nyní, při vzpomenutí, že máme pevné a, o němž mluvíme, zatímco sčítáme přes všechny
možné volby b,
tento bracket právě zde bude
vždy roven nule, když b se nerovná a, takže nebude žádný
příspěvek k součtu,
a když se b rovná a, bracket bude roven jedné, a tak nám zbude
tato jedna složka právě zde.
To je vzorec, který jsme chtěli, a tak máme velmi pěkný a jednoduchý způsob vyjádření funkce jako matice.
Kromě deterministických operací máme také operace, které
samy o sobě zavádějí náhodnost nebo nejistotu ohledně
klasického stavu systému.
Používáme termín pravděpodobnostní operace pro označení takových operací, a abychom byli přesní, když říkáme pravděpodobnostní operace,
myslíme tím operace, které
mohou zavádět náhodnost, takže deterministické operace jsou vlastně speciálním případem
pravděpodobnostních operací,
které se jen nestane, že
zavádějí jakoukoli náhodnost.
Tady je jednoduchý příklad, kde
je zavedena určitá náhodnost.
Toto je operace na jednom bitu. Způsob, jakým funguje, je ten, že pokud je klasický stav
bitu nula,
pak se nic nestane. Bit zůstane nulou, ale pokud je klasický
stav bitu jedna, pak operace převrátí bit na nulu
WEBVTT
s pravděpodobností rovnou 1/2.
Tato operace nemá žádný zvláštní název,
alespoň ne podle mého vědomí.
Je to jen příklad, ale můžeš si představit, že
tuto operaci provádíš na bitu.
Stejně jako deterministické operace, pravděpodobnostní operace mohou
být reprezentovány maticemi, a jejich działání na pravděpodobnostních stavech
jsou dána maticovým násobením vektoru, stejně jako předtím.
Tentokrát to nutně není tak, že matice mají přesně jednu jedničku v každém sloupci a jinak nuly.
Pravděpodobnostní operace jsou
obecněji reprezentovány stochastickými maticemi.
Jsou to matice, jejichž složky jsou všechny
nezáporná reálná čísla a kde součet složek v
každém sloupci je roven jedné.
To je ekvivalentní tomu říci,
že stochastické matice jsou matice, kde každý sloupec
tvoří vektor pravděpodobností.
To dává smysl, když uvažuješ o
działání matice na standardní bázový vektor.
Uvažuješ, jaký
klasický stav si přeješ, a představíš si, že ho vkládáš do vrcholu matice v příslušném sloupci odpovídajícím
tomuto klasickému stavu,
a tento sloupec ti říká, jaký
je pravděpodobnostní stav, který vyjde jako vektor pravděpodobností.
Pravděpodobnostní operace
v našem příkladu je například popsána touto maticí právě zde.
Pokud provedeme tuto operaci
na klasickém stavu nula, pak pravděpodobnostní stav, který dostaneme, je dán prvním sloupcem,
což je opět klasický stav nula, neboli ekvivalentně, pravděpodobnostní
stav, kde nula nastane s pravděpodobností jedna.
Pokud místo toho provedeme tuto operaci na klasickém stavu jedna, pak v podstatě jen bit náhodně změníme, a odpovídajícím způsobem dostaneme
tento vektor pravděpodobností zde,
kde pravděpodobnost pro
každý z možných stavů se rovná 1/2.
Obecně, pokud provedeme tuto operaci na jakémkoliv pravděpodobnostním stavu, pak efekt je v podstatě
jen váženým průměrem mezi dvěma sloupci,
protože takto funguje maticové násobení
vektoru.
Je lineární, takže jen průměrujeme dva
možné výsledky odpovídajícím způsobem.
Když uvažujeme o pravděpodobnostních
operacích tímto způsobem, je přirozené přemýšlet o
nich jako o potenciálním zavádění nebo vkládání náhodnosti.
Můžeme si jen číst sloupce jeden po druhém a vidíme náhodnost,
kterou zavádějí pro každý možný klasický stav.
Můžeš také přemýšlet o
pravděpodobnostních operacích trochu jinak, totiž že jsou to náhodné volby deterministických operací.
Například, v našem příkladu, o této operaci můžeme přemýšlet jako ekvivalentní
k hodení spravedlivou mincí
a buď provedení
konstantní nulové funkce, nebo funkce identity,
každé s pravděpodobností 1/2,
a to vidíš zde odrazem
v této rovnici.
To je vždy možné pro
jakoukoli pravděpodobnostní operaci, a je to celkem intuitivní.
Pokud bys dělal náhodné volby
jako část nějakého procesu, mohl bys si vždy představit, že tyto náhodné volby provádíš předem
a pak je pevně zapíšeš
do nějaké kolekce deterministických operací.
Někdy je celkem užitečné přemýšlet o pravděpodobnostních
operacích tímto způsobem, a příklad toho uvidíme
za pár lekcí.
Poslední věc, kterou je třeba říci
o klasických informacích pro tuto lekci, se týká skládání
pravděpodobnostních operací, což jednoduše znamená jejich provádění
jedna za druhou.
Předpokládejme, že
máme nějaký systém s názvem X a M1 až Mn jsou stochastické matice reprezentující pravděpodobnostní
operace na X.
Představ si nejprve, že máme
vektor pravděpodobností v, který reprezentuje pravděpodobnostní
stav X v nějakém okamžiku, a pak nejprve aplikujeme
první pravděpodobnostní operaci na X, která je reprezentována maticí M1, a pak aplikujeme druhou
pravděpodobnostní operaci,
která je reprezentována M2.
Pokud to uděláme, pak
vektor pravděpodobností, který dostaneme po aplikování jen první
operace, je M1 krát v,
a pak když aplikujeme
druhou operaci, výsledný vektor pravděpodobností je M2 vynásobené jakýmkoli vektorem, který jsme získali
po aplikování M1. Takže to vypadá takto.
Nyní, maticové násobení
je asociativní operace, což znamená, že nezáleží na tom, kde závorky umístíme.
Takže závorky bychom mohli stejně snadno
umístit takto.
To je velmi jednoduché, ale je to také zajímavé, protože nám to odhaluje, že
o operaci, kde nejprve aplikujeme M1,
a pak aplikujeme M2,
můžeme přemýšlet jako o jedné operaci.
Jinými slovy, pravděpodobnostní operace, kterou dostaneme skládáním první a
druhé pravděpodobnostní operace, je reprezentována
maticovým součinem M2 krát M1,
a to je stejná operace bez ohledu na to, s jakým pravděpodobnostním
stavem jsme začali.
Nemusíme nic vědět o vektoru pravděpodobností v, abychom o této složené operaci přemýšleli nebo ji popsali.
Všimni si, že pořadí
zde je M2 vlevo a M1 vpravo, což je proto, že
matice vpravo, M1,
je ta, která se
vynásobí k vektoru v, zatímco M2 se vynásobí
k jakémukoli vektoru, který dostaneme po vynásobení M1.
WEBVTT
Takže musíme mít vždy na paměti, že pořadí je v jistém
smyslu obráceno.
Operace provedená
jako první je ta vpravo, a operace, která se provede jako poslední, nebo v tomto případě jako druhá,
je ta vlevo.
Pokud se nezastavíme u druhé operace a aplikujeme všechny
v pořadí počínaje první a konče poslední, kterou je Mn,
pak složení všech
těchto operací dohromady je dáno tímto součinem,
který vidíš právě zde,
a vidíš, že pořadí
je opět obráceno přesně ze stejného důvodu jako předtím.
Stručně řečeno, složení
pravděpodobnostních operací jsou reprezentována součiny
stochastických matic, které je reprezentují.
Maje na paměti, že toto je
pořadí matic v součinu.
Vždy dostaneš stochastickou matici vynásobením stochastických
matic takto, a někdy tento fakt vyjadřujeme
tak, že stochastické
matice jsou uzavřeny pod násobením, a způsob, jak o tom
přemýšlet, je ten, že ze
množiny stochastických matic nemůžeš vyjít
jejich násobením, protože množina je uzavřena.
Vrátíme-li se k
pořadí matic v tomto součinu, je důležité poznamenat, že
pořadí skutečně záleží.
Maticové násobení není komutativní. Pokud změníš pořadí
matic v součinu, můžeš změnit výsledek,
a nemusíme se dívat dál než na deterministické
operace, abychom to viděli.
Tady je jednoduchý příklad
dvou stochastických matic, přičemž obě reprezentují
deterministické operace, kde záleží na pořadí.
M1 reprezentuje konstantní nulovou funkci. Předpokládáme, že si představujeme, že tyto dvě operace jsou na bitech, stejně jako v příkladu z dřívějška.
M2 reprezentuje operaci not
nebo bit flip.
Pokud nejprve provedeme M1
a pak provedeme M2, výsledek je tato matice právě zde, která reprezentuje
konstantní jednovou funkci.
Pokud nastavíš bit na nulu
a pak ho převrátíš, je to totéž jako jen
nastavit bit na jedničku.
Na druhou stranu, pokud nejprve provedeme M2
a pak provedeme M1, výsledek je tento právě zde,
a to dává smysl, protože pokud převrátíš bit
a pak ho nastavíš na nulu, je to totéž jako
jen ho nastavit na nulu.
Nezáleží na tom, že jsi ho převrátil. Zjevně tyto dvě
matice nejsou stejné, a tak máme velmi
jednoduchý příklad odhalující,
že pořadí záleží. Samozřejmě, toto vůbec není překvapivé.
Všichni víme, že pořadí, ve kterém
jsou operace prováděny, záleží, nebo alespoň může záležet.
Například, pokud zapálíš
zápalku a pak na ni foukneš, výsledek je velmi odlišný
od foukání na zápalku nejprve
a pak jejího zapálení. V tomto okamžiku jsme si toho dost o klasických informacích povídali, a nyní je konečně čas
diskutovat o kvantových informacích.
A zjistíme, že
matematicky řečeno, kvantové informace fungují
velmi podobným způsobem jako klasické informace
s některými klíčovými rozdíly.
První klíčový rozdíl
je hned na začátku — jak definujeme stav, v tomto případě kvantový stav systému,
a existuje smysl, v němž tato jedna volba — jak
definujeme kvantový stav — do značné míry určuje, jak
kvantové informace fungují.
Také definujeme, jak
fungují měření a operace, a v příští lekci probereme, jak
kvantové informace fungují nejen pro jednotlivé systémy,
ale pro více systémů,
ale tyto věci vlastně
docela přirozeně vyplývají, jakmile je pojem kvantového stavu jednoho systému
v izolaci ustaven.
Tady je definice. Kvantový stav systému je reprezentován sloupcovým vektorem, jehož indexy jsou dány
do korespondence s
klasickými stavy tohoto systému.
Předpokládáme tedy zde, že
systém, o němž mluvíme, má nějakou množinu klasických stavů, stejně jako když jsme mluvili
o klasických informacích
a pravděpodobnostních stavech. Složky vektoru kvantového stavu
jsou komplexní čísla, na rozdíl od pravděpodobnostního případu,
kde složky jsou
nezáporná reálná čísla.
A tentokrát musí součet absolutních
hodnot na druhou složek být roven jedné, na rozdíl od součtu rovnajícího se jedné,
jak máme v pravděpodobnostním případě.
Komplexní čísla, která se
vyskytují ve vektoru kvantového stavu, se někdy nazývají amplitudy a hrají roli podobnou pravděpodobnostem,
ale nejsou to pravděpodobnosti a nemají
stejnou interpretaci.
Nemohu ti dát dobrý důvod, proč by kvantové stavy
měly být takto definovány, jinak než říct, že
fyzici zjistili,
že tato definice
je fyzikálně relevantní a umožňuje nám popisovat a modelovat
kvantové mechanické systémy.
Jinými slovy, tuto definici volíme
protože funguje, ne proto, že existují
nějaké konkrétní důvody, proč by kvantové stavy měly
být takto definovány.
S ohledem na
matematiku tohoto pojmu kvantového stavu je prvním krokem k jeho pochopení a práci s ním
připomenutí si této definice
pro eukleidovskou normu vektoru, o které můžeš geometricky přemýšlet jako o délce vektoru, stejně jako bys přemýšlel o délce
dvourozměrného reálného vektoru, kdybys ho nakreslil na papír jako šipku začínající z počátku obvyklým způsobem.
WEBVTT
Konkrétně, pokud máme
sloupcový vektor v takový, o němž předpokládáme, že má
složky komplexních čísel, alfa jedna až alfa n,
pak eukleidovská norma v je definována jak vidíš právě zde.
Toto je notace, kterou
používáme pro eukleidovskou normu, přičemž tyto dvojité čáry jsou umístěny kolem jakéhokoli vektoru, o němž mluvíme.
V tomto případě je to v, a způsob, jakým je eukleidovská norma definována, je ten, že to je druhá odmocnina součtu
absolutních hodnot na druhou
složek vektoru.
Takže jiný způsob definice toho, co
je vektor kvantového stavu, je, že vektor kvantového stavu je sloupcový vektor mající
složky komplexních čísel,
jehož eukleidovská norma se rovná jedné, což znamená, že je to jednotkový vektor s ohledem na eukleidovskou normu.
Je to proto, že součet
absolutní hodnoty na druhou se rovná jedné právě tehdy, když eukleidovská
norma se rovná jedné.
Druhá odmocnina nic nemění, když součet absolutních
hodnot na druhou se rovná jedné.
Takže to je vektor kvantového stavu. Je to sloupcový vektor s indexy, které odpovídají
klasickým stavům systému,
mající složky komplexních čísel a eukleidovskou normu rovnou jedné.
Co to znamená nebo co to implikuje nebo jak bychom měli interpretovat tento
pojem, to je jiná záležitost, a v jistém smyslu
studium kvantových
informací a výpočtů je průzkumem toho, co
tato definice implikuje, alespoň z hlediska
zpracování informací.
Toto je jednoduše výchozí bod.
Jako vsuvku, dovolte mi zmínit, že existují
jiné tzv. normy kromě eukleidovské normy, a tato notace právě zde s dvojitými čarami
kolem vektoru neznamená vždy
eukleidovskou normu.
V různých kontextech může tato notace odkazovat
na jinou normu.
Například, součet
absolutních hodnot bez mocnin nebo odmocniny je jinou normou,
často nazývanou jedna-norma. Existuje vlastně celkem hodně
různých norem.
Někdy uvidíš
tuto notaci použitou s dolním indexem za
druhými čarami, který poskytuje více informací o tom, o jaké normě mluvíme.
A když to uděláme, je celkem typické, že číslo dvě jako dolní index
znamená eukleidovskou normu.
Ale v této sérii, kdykoli máme
sloupcový vektor jako tento, tato notace s dvojitými čarami sama o sobě
znamená eukleidovskou normu.
Tady je několik příkladů
vektorů kvantového stavu, a tyto konkrétní vektory kvantového stavu jsou vektory stavu qubitů,
což znamená, že
klasické stavy našeho systému jsou nula a jedna.
Slovo qubit je zkrácenina pro kvantový bit, což je vlastně jen bit,
který může být v kvantovém stavu.
První dva příklady jsou velmi jednoduché. Vektory standardní báze
ket nula a ket jedna jsou vektory kvantového stavu.
Oba jsou sloupcové vektory a indexy odpovídají
klasickým stavům nula a jedna, a složky těchto
vektorů jsou komplexní čísla.
Pro tyto konkrétní vektory jsou složky nula a jedna, což jsou reálná čísla, a vlastně jsou to celá čísla, ale jsou to také komplexní čísla,
která se stane, že mají
imaginární část rovnou nule.
Každý vektor má jednu složku rovnou jedné a jednu složku rovnou nule.
Takže když sečteme absolutní
hodnoty složek, dostaneme jedničku v obou případech.
Takže podmínky
potřebné pro to, aby tyto vektory byly vektory kvantového stavu, jsou splněny.
Následující dva příklady jsou velmi běžně se vyskytující stavy qubitů, nazývané plus stav a minus stav.
Jsou označeny, jak
vidíš na obrazovce, buď jako ket plus
nebo ket minus takto, a jsou definovány, jak vidíš právě zde.
Opět, složky těchto
vektorů jsou komplexní čísla. Tentokrát jsou buď kladná jedna dělená druhou odmocninou dvou, nebo záporná jedna dělená druhou odmocninou dvou,
a když sečteme
absolutní hodnoty na druhou, dostaneme 1/2 plus 1/2, což je jedna.
Mimochodem, vkládat
znaménko plus nebo minus dovnitř ketu takto
může vypadat trochu zvláštně, protože to nejsou klasické
stavy našeho systému,
ale tato notace se přesto používá, a k tomu se za chvíli vrátíme.
Ale prozatím, stručně řečeno, můžeme Diracovu notaci použít a vložit dovnitř ketu jakýkoliv název pro vektor.
Vektor nemusí být
vektorem standardní báze, když používáme Diracovu notaci.
Tady je zatím poslední příklad stavu qubitů.
Je to vektor kvantového stavu qubitů, který nemá žádný zvláštní název, a není zvláště významný.
Složky tohoto vektoru jsou jedna plus dvě krát i
děleno třemi a záporné 2/3.
Jsou to komplexní čísla, a pokud vypočítáš
absolutní hodnoty na druhou těchto dvou složek, dostaneš 5/9 pro první
a 4/9 pro druhou. Takže součet absolutní
hodnoty na druhou se rovná jedné.
A tady je ještě jeden poslední příklad. Tentokrát pro systém,
jehož klasické stavy jsou čtyři barvy karet.
Nevím, proč bychom měli systém, jehož klasické stavy
jsou čtyři barvy karet, který je v kvantovém stavu, ale v principu je to možné
a je to jen zamýšleno jako příklad.
WEBVTT
Složky odpovídající
různým barvám jsou 1/2 pro kříže, záporné
i děleno dvěma pro káry,
nula pro srdce, protože se ve součtu nevyskytuje, a jedna dělená druhou odmocninou
dvou pro piky.
A tady je to, jak to vypadá
jako sloupcový vektor, předpokládajíce, že jsme uspořádali
klasické stavy jako dříve,
což je pořadí, které
vidíš právě zde.
Vzít absolutní hodnotu
na druhou těchto složek dává čtvrtinu pro první, také čtvrtinu pro tu další.
Absolutní hodnota na druhou
nuly se rovná nule, takže tato složka nepřispívá
k součtu.
A nakonec, pro tu poslední dostaneme 1/2. Takže součet se rovná jedné, jak je potřeba pro tento vektor,
aby byl vektorem kvantového stavu.
Nyní, před chvílí, jsme použili notaci
ket plus a ket minus pro odkázání na dva vektory stavu qubitů, které nejsou vektory standardní báze.
Chtěl bych se k
tomuto bodu stručně vrátit a vysvětlit, jak se Diracova notace používá pro libovolné vektory a nejen pro vektory standardní báze.
Jak jsem již zmínil, můžeme použít jakýkoliv název, který
chceme, uvnitř bry nebo ketu pro odkázání na vektor.
Kety jsou sloupcové vektory
a bry jsou řádkové vektory, stejně jako předtím.
Jako příklad, řecké písmeno
psi je velmi běžně používáno uvnitř ketu pro odkázání na nějaký libovolný vektor,
a zde ho používáme pro
pojmenování vektoru stavu, který dříve neměl
žádný zvláštní název.
Když to uděláme, řecké písmeno psi
nemusí nutně mít sám o sobě žádný význam.
Je to jen název vektoru, a je uvnitř ketu, aby nám pomohl objasnit,
že se jedná o sloupcový vektor.
Toto může být někdy trochu
matoucí, a existuje potenciál pro nejednoznačnost, pokud by písmeno psi mohlo být spojeno
s klasickým stavem
nějakého systému například, ale obecně to nezpůsobuje žádné problémy, a nemusíš Diracovu notaci takto používat,
pokud nechceš. Použití malého písmene jako
u, v nebo w bez ketu je také dobrý způsob, jak
označit sloupcový vektor,
nebo konkrétněji,
vektor kvantového stavu.
Je na tobě, jakou notaci
používáš k vyjadřování.
Jen se musíš ujistit,
že za prvé je smysl toho, co
se snažíš vyjádřit, jasný ostatním.
A za druhé, že rozumíš tomu, co
se ostatní snaží vyjádřit, i když jejich preference pro notaci nejsou stejné jako tvé.
Existuje jedno velmi důležité pravidlo pro používání Diracovy notace
pro libovolné vektory, a to je, že pokud máš sloupcový vektor,
který ses rozhodl zapsat
jako ket psi, například, nebo by mohl být jiný
název uvnitř ketu, pak řádkový vektor bra psi
se chápe jako
konjugovaný transponát vektoru ket psi.
A zde je to zapsáno jako rovnice, kde tato dýka právě zde odkazuje na konjugovaný transponát.
Co to konkrétně je, je
řádkový vektor, který dostaneš, za prvé transponováním vektoru, což znamená, že vektor překlopíš na bok a změníš ho ze sloupce na řádek
bez skutečné změny složek. A za druhé, vzít komplexní sdruženou hodnotu
každé ze složek.
Vlastně můžeš provést
tyto dvě operace, transponování a
složkový komplexní sdružený, v libovolném pořadí, nebo tyto
dvě operace komutují.
Takže pro vektor v tomto příkladu, dáno, že jsme se rozhodli
nazvat tento vektor ket psi, chápe se, že bra psi
znamená tento vektor právě zde,
kde jsme transponovali vektor přeměnou ket nula a ket
jedna na bra nula a bra jedna, a vzali jsme komplexní sdružené každé složky,
proto jedna plus
dvě krát i děleno třemi se změní na jedna minus dvě
krát i děleno třemi právě zde.
Tady je, jak tyto vektory vypadají, když jsou zapsány
explicitně jako sloupcový vektor a řádkový vektor.
Mimochodem, toto pravidlo je konzistentní s notací, kterou používáme, když máme klasické stavy
uvnitř bry a ketu.
V takovém případě jsou
všechny složky nula, kromě jedné jedničky, takže vzít komplexní sdruženou v takovém případě nic neudělá.
Nyní jsme viděli, jak jsou kvantové stavy reprezentovány jako vektory, ale zatím není jasné, co to znamená nebo co to implikuje
z hlediska toho, co
lze se systémem v kvantovém stavu dělat nebo jak s ním lze interagovat.
První věc, kterou musíme udělat, abychom tyto otázky přivedli do ohniska,
je probrat měření.
Intuitivně řečeno,
měření poskytují mechanismus pro extrahování klasických
informací z kvantových systémů.
Když se na systém podíváme,
když je v kvantovém stavu, nevidíme kvantový stav, stejně jako nevidíme
pravděpodobnostní stavy,
vidíme klasické stavy, a právě tento pojem měření poskytuje rozhraní.
Pokud chceme jako lidé vědět něco o kvantovém systému, musíme ho měřit, a tím extrahujeme klasické informace
o jakémkoliv kvantovém
stavu, ve kterém se ten systém nacházel.
Existují různé
pojmy měření. Rozdíl je vlastně v obecnosti, a začneme s nejjednodušším a nejzákladnějším,
který se obvykle nazývá
měření ve standardní bázi.
WEBVTT
V následujících lekcích toto zobecníme. Probereme tzv.
projektivní měření ve třetí lekci, a pak later v
třetí jednotce série,
probereme obecná měření, která se také nazývají míry s kladnou hodnotou operátoru neboli zkráceně POVMs.
Ale prozatím omezíme pozornost na měření ve standardní bázi.
Když je na systému provedeno měření, bude existovat určitá množina
možných výsledků tohoto měření, což jsou klasické výsledky,
a v případě
měření ve standardní bázi, tyto možné výsledky jsou
přesně klasické stavy jakéhokoli systému, který je měřen.
Každý z těchto klasických stavů bude výsledkem měření s určitou pravděpodobností, a tato pravděpodobnost je absolutní hodnota na druhou
složky odpovídající
tomuto klasickému stavu v jakémkoli vektoru kvantového stavu, ve kterém se systém nacházel bezprostředně před měřením.
Víme, že absolutní hodnota na druhou libovolného komplexního čísla je nezáporné reálné číslo, a víme z definice
vektorů kvantového stavu,
že součet absolutní
hodnoty na druhou složek vektoru kvantového stavu se rovná jedné.
Takže to dává smysl. Každý klasický stav se objeví jako výsledek
měření s určitou pravděpodobností, a pravděpodobnosti dávají dohromady jedničku.
Tady je několik příkladů. Nejprve předpokládejme, že máme
qubit v plus stavu.
Pokud měříme tento qubit s ohledem na měření ve
standardní bázi, dostaneme buď nulu, nebo
jedničku jako výsledek.
Pravděpodobnost získání nuly je absolutní hodnota
na druhou z jedna děleno druhou odmocninou dvou, což je 1/2, a to je stejná
pravděpodobnost získání jedničky.
Takže pokud změříš plus stav, dostaneš uniformní náhodný bit.
Pokud je systém v minus
stavu místo plus stavu, pak měření funguje
přesně stejným způsobem.
Pravděpodobnosti jsou opět 1/2 pro každý možný výsledek.
Jediný rozdíl zde je, že znaménko plus se změnilo na minus, ale když vezmeme absolutní
hodnotu, nic se nemění.
Pokud měříme tento stav qubitů, pravděpodobnost získání výsledku nula je absolutní hodnota na druhou z jedna plus dvě krát i
děleno třemi, což je 5/9,
a pravděpodobnost získání výsledku jedna je absolutní hodnota na druhou
z záporných 2/3, což je 4/9.
A nakonec, měření
stavu standardní báze, ket nula, dá výsledek
nula s jistotou, a podobně měření stavu ket jedna
dá výsledek jedna s jistotou. To proto, že absolutní
hodnota na druhou z jedničky je jedna.
Podobně jako v
pravděpodobnostním nastavení, můžeme tyto kvantové
stavy, ket nula a ket jedna, spojovat se systémem, který je
v těchto klasických stavech,
a tento příklad je konzistentní
s touto interpretací.
Nyní, stejně jako v
pravděpodobnostním nastavení, pokud měříme systém, když
je v kvantovém stavu,
pak se stav obecně změní v důsledku provedení
tohoto měření.
Konkrétně, a opět, to je přesně jako v
pravděpodobnostním nastavení.
Pokud měříme systém a výsledkem měření
je klasický stav a, pak nový kvantový stav
systému se stane ket a.
Takže pro tento stav právě
zde, například, vidíme stejný druh
chování, který jsme měli v pravděpodobnostním nastavení.
Pokud měříme, pak s pravděpodobností 5/9 dostaneme výsledek nula, v takovém případě stav
přejde na ket nula,
a s pravděpodobností
4/9 je výsledek jedna, a stav přejde na ket jedna.
Tento jev se někdy označuje jako kolaps
kvantového stavu, a je to druh věci, která drží lidi,
kteří studují základy
kvantové mechaniky, v noci vzhůru.
Ale z čistě
matematické perspektivy je to opravdu zcela jednoduché
a velmi analogické tomu, co máme v pravděpodobnostním případě.
Zdroj napětí zde se v jistém smyslu týká fundamentální
podstaty kvantových stavů a toho, co reprezentují,
a jak se liší
od pravděpodobnostních stavů. Ale na matematické úrovni je to možná to, co bys čekal.
Všimni si mimochodem, že pokud bys měřil podruhé, dostaneš přesně
stejný výsledek jako při prvním měření.
Takže existuje limit na to, kolik
klasických informací může být extrahováno z kvantového stavu, a k tomuto bodu se brzy vrátíme
v jiné lekci. Promluvili jsme si o kvantových stavech i o měřeních, konkrétně o měřeních ve standardní bázi,
která poskytují způsob
extrahování klasických informací z kvantových stavů.
Zbývajícím tématem pro
tuto lekci jsou operace, konkrétně unitární operace, které popisují, jak lze kvantové stavy systémů
měnit. Přirozeně, dáno, že vektory kvantového stavu jsou odlišné od vektorů pravděpodobností, očekával bys, že množina přípustných operací
na kvantových stavech je odlišná od toho, co máme pro
klasické informace, a skutečně tomu tak je.
Zatímco operace na pravděpodobnostních stavech jsou reprezentovány stochastickými maticemi, operace na vektorech kvantového stavu
jsou reprezentovány unitárními maticemi.
Tady je definice unitárních matic.
Čtvercová matice U mající složky
komplexních čísel je unitární, pokud splňuje rovnice,
které vidíš právě zde.
WEBVTT
Dýka reprezentuje
konjugovaný transponát, který jsme již viděli u vektorů, když jsme mluvili o Diracově notaci před chvílí.
Zde provádíme
konjugovaný transponát na matici, nikoli na vektoru, ale je to v podstatě totéž.
Transponujeme matici, což jednoduše znamená, že prohodíme řádky a sloupce, takže složka JK se stane složkou KJ,
a také bereme komplexní sdruženou
každé složky.
Také tato notace právě zde
znamená matici identity.
Tyto dvě rovnosti právě
zde jsou vlastně ekvivalentní. Pokud máš jednu, pak
automaticky máš druhou.
Obě jsou ekvivalentní
tomu říci, že U je invertibilní a inverzní se rovná
konjugovanému transponátu.
To platí pouze pro čtvercové
matice, mimochodem. Pokud máš matici, která není čtvercová, pak jedna z těchto dvou
rovností může platit,
ale pak druhá platit nebude.
Ale zde mluvíme
o čtvercových maticích.
Takže toto je standardní
definice pro unitární matice, a je hezká, protože je snadné zkontrolovat,
zda je matice unitární.
Jednoduše vynásobíš matici jejím konjugovaným transponátem na obou stranách, a uvidíš, zda dostaneš
matici identity.
Existuje ekvivalentní způsob charakterizace unitárních matic, a to, že
čtvercová matice je unitární právě tehdy, když nikdy
nemění eukleidovskou normu
jakéhokoli vektoru, když násobíš. N krát N matice U je unitární právě tehdy, když eukleidovská norma U krát v
se rovná eukleidovské normě v pro každý n-rozměrný sloupcový vektor v se složkami komplexních čísel.
A proto, pokud v je
vektor kvantového stavu, pak U krát v je také
vektor kvantového stavu, protože vektory kvantového stavu
jsou jednoduše vektory mající
eukleidovskou normu rovnou jedné.
Vlastně můžeme říci o trochu více, totiž že unitární matice jsou přesně matice, které vždy transformují
vektory kvantového stavu
na vektory kvantového stavu. To je podobná situace tomu, co máme pro stochastické matice
a vektory pravděpodobností.
Stochastické matice
jsou přesně matice, které vždy transformují vektory pravděpodobností na vektory pravděpodobností.
Takže jakmile jsme se rozhodli, že operace by měly být reprezentovány maticemi, což je totéž jako říci, že transformace působí lineárně
na vektory reprezentující stavy, tyto volby pro množiny přípustných operací přirozeně vyplývají, alespoň
z matematického hlediska.
Nyní se podívejme na některé příklady unitárních operací na qubitech.
V následujících lekcích uvidíme mnoho dalších příkladů
unitárních operací, včetně unitárních operací a systémů
majících více než dva klasické stavy. Ale prozatím se zaměříme jen
na unitární operace na qubitech.
Tyto konkrétní příklady se
budeme setkávat znovu a znovu, takže rozhodně stojí za to
tyto operace poznat.
První kolekce příkladů jsou tzv. Pauliho operace.
Jsou to operace odpovídající Pauliho maticím, které jsou zobrazeny zde.
Jsou všechny unitární, a to můžeš zkontrolovat pro každou z nich podle definice z dřívějška.
Tyto konkrétní matice
se stane, že se rovnají svým vlastním konjugovaným transponátům, což znamená, že jsou
všechny Hermitovské matice.
Takže kontrola toho, zda jsou
všechny unitární, je v tomto případě věcí umocnění každé z nich na druhou a zjištění, zda výsledek
je matice identity.
Názvy, které vidíš pro tyto
matice, jsou celkem standardní, a také uvidíš
sigma x, sigma y a sigma z nazývané jednoduše X, Y a Z.
Mej ale na paměti, že
velká písmena X, Y a Z jsou také běžně používána pro jiné účely, dokonce i v kontextu
kvantových informací,
ale jsou to velmi běžné
názvy pro tyto matice.
Operace sigma x nebo X
se také nazývá bit flip nebo operace not, kterou jsme již viděli
v klasickém kontextu.
A operace sigma z nebo Z
se také nazývá phase flip.
A zde vidíš
działání těchto operací na vektory standardní báze, což trochu vysvětluje,
odkud tyto názvy pochází.
Jistě dává smysl
označovat sigma x jako bit flip, na základě tohoto działání právě zde.
Jednoduše převrátí bit z
nuly na jedničku nebo z jedničky na nulu.
Také dává smysl
nazývat sigma z phase flip na základě tohoto działání právě zde.
Ale pokud to není v tuto chvíli naprosto jasné, to je v pořádku.
S touto operací se
budeme setkávat znovu a znovu, a significance
vkládání záporného znaménka před ket jedna
bázový vektor a ne ket nula
a proč se to nazývá phase flip bude jasnější later.
Dalším příkladem je
operace Hadamard, která je reprezentována
touto maticí právě zde, která se téměř vždy označuje H.
Ověření, že H je unitární, je opět
přímočarý výpočet, který, pokud ustoupím z cesty, vidíš právě zde.
Podobně jako Pauliho matice, H je svůj vlastní konjugovaný transponát.
Takže máme tuto rovnici právě zde, a když provedeme násobení, dostaneme matici identity, jak je potřeba.
WEBVTT
Třetím příkladem je
vlastně celá třída unitárních operací
známých jako fázové operace.
Jsou to operace
reprezentované jakoukoli maticí, která má tento tvar,
který vidíš právě zde, kde theta je libovolné reálné číslo.
Takže tato složka právě zde bude
vždy nějaké komplexní číslo na jednotkové kružnici.
Matice jako tato jsou vždy unitární, což ti nechám ověřit.
Tentokrát konjugovaný transponát se nebude rovnat původní matici, pokud toto číslo zde se náhodou
nerovná jedné nebo záporné jedné,
v takovém případě skončíme buď
s maticí identity, nebo sigma z, se kterou jsme
se již setkali.
Konkrétně, transponování
nebude na tuto matici mít žádný efekt, ale vzít komplexní sdruženou každé složky změní tuto složku právě zde
na e na záporné i theta.
Tyto dvě konkrétní operace právě zde jsou obzvláště důležité
příklady fázových operací.
Pro první vezmeme
theta rovno pi lomeno dvěma, a dostaneme tuto matici právě zde.
Tato se běžně nazývá
operace S nebo S gate, když mluvíme o circuit, o nichž v této lekci nebudeme diskutovat,
ale to je důležité
téma, které brzy přijde.
Druhá je tato operace. Je to operace T nebo T gate.
A pro tuto,
theta se rovná pi lomeno čtyřmi. A tak když vypočítáme exponenciálu, dostaneme tuto hodnotu právě zde, což je jedna plus i děleno
druhou odmocninou dvou.
Tady je jen několik rychlých příkladů, jak vidět tyto
operace v działání.
Tady je działání
operace Hadamard na ket nula a ket jedna.
Pokud projdeme
maticové násobení vektoru, vidíme, že co dostaneme jsou plus stav a
minus stav, v tomto pořadí.
Pokud provedeme operaci Hadamard na plus stavu a
minus stavu, na druhou stranu, dostaneme zpět ket nula a ket jedna.
Takže pokud trochu vyčistíme věci, vidíme działání jasněji.
Operace Hadamard
transformuje tam a zpět mezi nulovým stavem a plus stavem, a mezi jedničkovým stavem
a minus stavem.
Ohledně těchto dvou rovnic právě zde, všimni si, že nám to dává jednoduchý způsob, jak rozeznat rozdíl mezi plus stavem a minus stavem.
Jak jsme viděli dříve v lekci, pokud měříme plus
stav a minus stav s ohledem na měření ve
standardní bázi,
dostaneme uniformní náhodný bit v obou případech, což nám nepomáhá
rozeznat rozdíl.
Ale pokud provedeme operaci Hadamard a pak měříme, uvidíme nulu, pokud
původní stav byl plus stav,
a jedničku, pokud původní
stav byl minus stav.
Takže tyto dva stavy jsou skutečně různé, a lze je dokonale rozlišit
metodou, kterou jsem právě popsal,
která spočívá v tom, že nejprve
provedeme operaci Hadamard a pak měříme.
Vrátíme-li se k příkladu
stavu qubitů, který jsme viděli dříve a který není zvláště speciální, můžeme vidět, co operace Hadamard udělá se stavem,
převodem do tvarů,
které vidíš právě zde, a provedením násobení.
A tady je výsledek,
který můžeme převést zpět do Diracovy notace, pokud si přejeme,
a to je jeden způsob výpočtu
těchto druhů działání.
Tady je další příklad, který ilustruje, že nemusíš vždy
explicitně převádět do tvaru matice-vektor.
Tyto výpočty také lze provést
přímo pomocí Diracovy notace.
Tento příklad se týká operace T, a tady je právě zde
jen pro referenci.
Tato operace má toto działání právě zde na stavech standardní báze.
A pokud chceme vypočítat
działání operace T na plus stav, například, můžeme začít rozvinutím
definice plus stavu
a pak použít linearitu
k vyjádření výsledku, jak vidíš právě zde.
Nyní stačí jen dosadit
tyto výrazy nahoru, provést trochu
zjednodušení pro druhý člen, a dostaneme výsledek.
Pokud z jakéhokoli důvodu chceme aplikovat operaci Hadamard
na výsledek, můžeme udělat podobnou věc.
Nejprve dosadíme výraz pro T působící na plus stav, a použijeme linearitu, jako jsme to udělali dříve.
A nyní, pokud dosadíme
výrazy, které již máme, pro operaci Hadamard
působící na ket nula a ket jedna,
dostaneme toto. A nyní můžeme rozvinout plus stav a minus stav a dostat tento výraz právě zde,
který můžeme zjednodušit jen sečtením, a tady je konečný výsledek.
Na tomto příkladu není nic zvláště
zvláštního. Je jen zamýšlen
ilustrovat tento alternativní, ale ekvivalentní způsob výpočtu działání
těchto operací. Můžeš použít jakýkoli
způsob, který je pohodlnější v dané situaci.
Poslední poznámka o
unitárních operacích je, že složení unitárních
operací je reprezentováno maticovým násobením,
stejně jako v pravděpodobnostním nastavení, tj. dapat vypočítat działání sekvence unitárních operací
jednoduše vynásobením
matic dohromady. A co dostaneš, je
jedna unitární matice reprezentující kombinované działání
WEBVTT
sekvence operací.
Stejně jako pro stochastické matice, unitární matice jsou
uzavřeny pod násobením, takže vždy dostaneš unitární matici,
když skládáš unitární operace.
Musíš se ujistit,
že matice násobíš ve správném pořadí.
Ale způsob, jakým to funguje, je stejný jako pro
stochastické operace, kde matice pro
první operaci, kterou provedeš,
bude vždy na pravé straně
maticového součinu, a poslední bude
na levé straně.
Takže stejně jako předtím, pořadí je v tom smyslu obráceno, že skládáš zprava doleva, ne zleva doprava.
Tady je zajímavý příklad, který dává vzniknout operaci známé jako druhá odmocnina operace not.
Předpokládejme, že nejprve
aplikujeme operaci Hadamard, po níž následuje operace S, po níž následuje další operace Hadamard.
Kombinované działání
těchto tří operací je popsáno tímto součinem.
Tady je první operace Hadamard, tady je operace S, a tady je druhá operace Hadamard.
Pokud provedeme maticové násobení, které není zde explicitně zobrazeno, ale to můžeš udělat
sám, pokud chceš,
výsledek je tato matice právě zde. Je to unitární matice, a to můžeme buď zkontrolovat přímo,
nebo můžeme důvěřovat skutečnosti, že unitární matice jsou
uzavřeny pod násobením.
Musí být unitární, protože tyto tři matice jsou unitární, jak jsme již viděli.
Nemáme na mysli žádný konkrétní
vektor kvantového stavu.
Můžeme si představit provedení
této sekvence operací na jakémkoli vektoru kvantového stavu, a tato matice popisuje działání.
Důvod, proč se tato kombinovaná operace, tj. ta popsaná
touto maticí právě zde, nazývá druhá odmocnina operace not,
je, že jejím provedením
dvakrát dostaneme operaci not, neboli jinými slovy,
operaci sigma x nebo X.
Provedení operace
dvakrát je reprezentováno umocněním matice nebo jejím vynásobením sama sebou.
A pokud to uděláš, uvidíš, že výsledek
je Pauliho matice x.
A to je trochu zvláštní, a dává ti to jen náznak toho, že s kvantovými informacemi lze dělat zajímavé věci, které klasickými informacemi dělat nemůžeš.
Neexistuje žádná klasická operace, tj. taková reprezentovaná
stochastickou maticí, která nám dá operaci not,
pokud ji provedeme dvakrát.
Takže je to hezký příklad, který odhaluje, že kvantové operace
se chovají velmi odlišně od klasických operací.
A to je vše pro první lekci. V této lekci jsme probrali, jak kvantové informace fungují pro jednotlivé systémy v izolaci,
a v příští lekci si promluvíme o tom, jak
kvantové informace fungují pro více systémů.
Díky za sledování. Pokud máš jakékoli otázky, neváhej je zanechat
v sekci komentářů níže.